se nos dice que la figura 2 es una copia
escala de la figura 1 y podemos
verificar esto si comparamos los datos
correspondientes los lados
correspondientes son lados que tienen la
misma posición relativa que juegan el
mismo papel en cada uno de los diagramas
incluso si los diagramas son versiones a
escala uno del otro incluso si son de
diferentes tamaños entonces por ejemplo
si comparamos el segmento ea parece que
corresponde al segmento ope y la
longitud de a es igual a tres la
longitud de ope es 123456 y para que
esto sea una copia escala el factor de
escala para convertir el lado
correspondiente de la figura uno en el
lado correspondiente de la figura 2 debe
ser un factor de 2 así que es x 2
entonces contestemos las preguntas que
nos hacen aquí y luego podremos
verificar si es una copia a escala
qué punto de la figura 1 corresponde al
punto q de la figura 2 muy bien pausa en
el vídeo y vean si pueden resolverlo
muy bien el punto cu de la figura 2 está
justo aquí qué punto de la figura 1
corresponde a este bueno el punto estará
jugando el mismo papel debe estar en la
misma posición relativa de modo que
parece que este punto que tenemos aquí
el punto b está en la misma posición
relativa el punto b es el que
corresponde al punto q de la figura 2
identifica el lado de la figura 2 que
corresponde al segmento de c en la
figura 1 pausa en el vídeo nuevamente y
ver si pueden resolverlo muy bien el
segmento de s de la figura 1 es este de
aquí y probablemente lo vieron casi de
inmediato el segmento que está en la
misma posición en la figura 2 es este
que tenemos aquí de modo que la
respuesta es el segmento nm voy a poner
la línea de arriba para asegurarme de
que estoy especificando un segmento una
vez más podemos verificar el factor de
escala para asegurarnos de que esta es
una copia escala
para que estas dos figuras sean
correspondientes entre sí para que sean
copias a escala entre sí d se tiene una
longitud de 12 34 inm tiene una longitud
de 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 entonces una vez más
estamos verificando que nuestro factor
de escala es 2 hasta el próximo vídeo